hello and welcome to the evan carmichael
show i believe in entrepreneurs and this
show is all about helping turn your
company into a success now funny story i
like to start off my mornings listening
to music stuff to get me kind of in the
zone and ready to start my day and just
before coming on this show i had bon
jovi it's my life plane and i'm belting
out it's my life at the top of my my
voice and it started to crack like
probably not the best thing to do before
going on the radio station but i am
excited to be here i want to welcome
back daniella my producer she was away
two weeks ago welcome back daniella we
missed you
today's show
is all about online marketing how to
market yourself online properly okay and
i'm going to be sharing some valuable
strategies and tips that i use to market
my business i'm also going to have a
guest edward kundal on later on in the
program who's an expert in local
marketing online and uh he's going to
share his tips and they want to get to
your calls too if you're struggling with
your business if you have a question
about online marketing about anything
with your company that's the fun part of
the show i love talking to you guys so
call in and let's have a chat
so let's get into it online marketing
look at your website is your website
generating a lot of leads for you or not
does it look like
you made it yourself or you had your
friend make it or does it look
professional is it a good representation
of your business
if you look at inc magazine they do an
annual list of the the fastest growing
companies in the country companies have
gone from nothing to millions of dollars
really quickly and you look at
what made them successful they always
ask what how do you market yourself how
do you sell your business and the number
one strategy that always comes back
consistently is online marketing it's
the most efficient way to reach
customers to reach new prospects to talk
about your business and these companies
are exploding from zero to millions in a
short amount of time by leveraging
online marketing i've had over 20
million people come and check out my
website and i love using as a tool to
drive new leads and generate new
business and so this show is about
helping you do the same i'm going to be
sharing some tools that i use and then
we're going to talk to ed later on the
program as well
okay now as much as i love using
traditional media and social media and
you know things like this radio show if
i could only pick one thing to do
it'd be my website this is this is too
important to ignore
here's an example here's why okay when
people are searching online they have a
problem
they have a problem and they need help
and you can help them right if somebody
is typing in san francisco plumber
they're not doing that because it's
something fun to do i'm going to google
and typing in san francisco plumber
is because i live in san francisco i
have a leak and i need a plumber right
that's a that's a lead for you right
there and whoever is coming up at the
top of the search engines for san
francisco plumber that guy or girl is
getting a lot of business and that
should be you
for your industry you want to be
dominating the search engines for your
specific industry to generate leads for
your business okay the first tool i want
to quickly introduce you to
is called google's keyword tool if you
go to google you type in google keyword
tool you'll find it and what it does is
whatever keyword you type in you can
type in anything related to your
business it'll show you a list of all
sorts of keyword options and how often
they're searched
so to tell you all the different
keywords that relate to your industry
how many times they're searched every
single month and then how competitive it
is
so you can figure out you know the the
ones that are massively popular they're
going to be really competitive and if
you don't have a popular website it's
going to be hard to rank for them what
you want to look for to the free google
keyword tool
is finding keywords that are targeted to
your industry that are not too
competitive and give yourself a good
chance to rank okay so that's my first
tool today the google keyword tool go
check it out it's free i want to get to
the calls that i have
sherry on hold sherry where are you from
and how can i help
hey evan i'm a jersey girl uh
williamstown and dirty
yeah you got an italian on the phone i'm
talking about italian too
yeah when you say half we basically mean
whole
but uh either which way yeah i got some
french irish for me too but i was raised
italian so
it is what it is
um anyway uh well i'm listening to you
um i have a big question for you
actually um i've been a paralegal for 22
years um recently i just became a
stay-at-home mom i have three sons of my
own and a future stepson
so
that's four boys
um i've been cooking
i've been cooking like my whole life
regardless i'm very passionate about it
you know grandma taught
out to the garden to grow my own garden
the whole nine yards and i really don't
have the opportunity right now to go out
and work in the physical field i can't
do the nine to five but you know running
down the ac working you know paralegal
job so i wanted to
talk to you see if there's any way like
i want to do something from home whether
it's jar my grandma's gravy or my fiance
is ukrainian and it's interesting that
we have a lot of flavors that they do
it's crazy like eggplant and all that
ah
so um i have i've had cans and stuff
before
i don't know how to get that online i
have no idea how to start it but i would
love you to tell me
so is that the business you want to
start online the training business
uh you know like make a website where i
can like you know make a product at home
and like ship it out to people i know
that's going to take a lot of work to do
or even if i just did it locally because
we i i'm buy tons of farms i'm down
south jersey i'm like 30 minutes from ac
so i have
lots of places i could start you know
bringing it to but
if if i could get somehow some way to do
the stuff from home
because like i said i got three three of
the smaller ones they just started
school today thank god
so i have time
from what's holding you back from
creating the product and then going to
even just local markets just to start
testing it out and get some feedback
i guess just because i'm not i'm not
knowledgeable on the business level of
it and i'm afraid that like i won't go
in there with the you know right
perspective of saying this is what i
want to do and how much i should make
off it how much they want to make
that that kind of thing
so i mean it doesn't like your research
it takes a little bit of research but
it's more confidence in yourself and
that you can do this like just because
you did you may didn't maybe didn't go
to school for business it doesn't mean
anything it's getting hands-on
experience and just believing in
yourself right i think the best thing is
you just start getting some momentum
because it can be hard creating in a
vacuum your home you know with the kids
by yourself and
you know when you're out talking to
customers and getting some feedback and
you see people's eyes light up when
they're tasting your stuff that helps
give you some extra motivation to keep
going
so what i would do that's exactly what i
want
just start small i would start small
start local start start painting your
stuff
and and go to a local
if there's a bake sale or a flea market
or an opportunity to do a day at a
outside of a local retailer
and sell your stuff and and test it like
text you're gonna learn you're gonna
make so many mistakes at the beginning
and that's okay and you have to figure
out all the business stuff like how to
sort your product and how to get your
costs down and how to market it and how
to price it and all that and it's better
to make all those mistakes on a small
scale
before exactly
and becomes the next greatest you know
food product
um
it's just getting some momentum right
like for getting
out of just being by yourself with this
idea and starting to interact with some
people and getting their feedback on it
so if you already have
some of it ready i would look at the
next farmer's market coming up or the
next flea market or if you know a
retailer that you can do a day with them
just something to start getting it
tasted and tried and get feedback and
start building a little bit of momentum
for the business that will pour a lot of
love and energy back into you
to help you keep
going but i've been awesome and not to
not to sort of in there real quick but
it just made something dawn on me i
literally just like last weekend became
the secretary for my i live in the lakes
um i just became the secretary on the
board
so
uh i can like we're gonna have a couple
you know like festivals and stuff coming
up so that would be a great opportunity
right for me to bring my stuff over
there
yeah it's a great start that's a perfect
start and even if the first ones are for
charity you're raising money for a good
cause whatever it is just to start
building some awareness but more
importantly for you to start feeling
validated and have some momentum and
feel like this could actually take off
yeah i'm smiling right now
i love it get to work and yeah i'm
looking forward to uh one day tasting
your stuff
well i hope you get to because i'm i'm
like soon as i get off the phone with
you i'm gonna go nuts and be like me
just think i needed a little shop that's
all
yeah and you know what everybody goes
through that too especially at the start
it's hard to to do things on your own in
a vacuum so as soon as you can start
getting some feedback from people i
think you're gonna you're gonna love
this idea and just have a little more
confidence in yourself as you go
yeah i'm confident in my cooking so i
know that i'm not gonna give anybody bad
food
all right thanks for calling italian
food now
all right take care evan cheers you know
for everybody calling in and and
thinking about you know growing a
business at the start it's really hard
to create in this vacuum so as soon as
you can get out there get some momentum
talk to people people try your stuff
have people interact with it and
this theme their faces light up
that gives you the motivation you need
today we're talking about online
marketing
and in the first segment i talked about
a tool called google keyword tools okay
this is a tool that can help you find
good keywords that you can rank for the
next step and again we're looking at
online marketing because it's one of the
most effective fastest ways to grow your
business and expand so now that you know
what your keyword is the next thing you
have to do is create content and this is
where a lot of people fall down because
the content they create just really
isn't all that good
you have to create content
that is spectacular that is amazing that
is awesome that makes people want to
pick up the phone and call you that
makes people want to share
right will people actually share content
from your website
probably not because it's too
promotional
you got to give people something that
they would actually forward on to
somebody you're going to give value
because the idea here is you're trying
to build a relationship with people
you're trying to build yourself up as
that expert so just having a sales page
isn't good enough that's not what's
going to get you ranked that's what's
going to get people talking about you
you have to put content that really
speaks to why you started this business
and give incredible value to your
customers
right do that and you're gonna start
getting ranked and make it targeted
around each specific keyword so you
gotta spend a lot more time working on
your content than just throwing up a
page but it will make all the difference
in the world
okay i want to get to the call i have
regime on hold and we were chatting on
twitter and i told mccullen so here he
is welcome to the program
hi everyone i want to discuss with you
something on the core selling of my
ayurvedic products which is
a very performance oriented product i
want to promote this product online and
i am not accelerating on sales can you
please help me out in generating
business out of india because my
products is of great value
what is the product here
ayurvedic products it's herbal medicines
herbal medicines
okay and why is this important to you it
is important to me because we are
generating sales in india i mean big
volumes but export marketing is becoming
tougher i have a good website but i
don't know what is wrong with the
promotion of the products
so you're trying to sell this stuff now
to what to an american market
uh yes
in the global market i would say it has
a very big market
outside india means i can name the
countries
uh its potential i have all the entire
data available with me but uh
i am finding it very difficult to
sell this product to the world rather
like united states of america germany
belgium united kingdom france
switzerland italy japan
these are some of the least i want to
promote my products maybe the write-up
is not good or something you may suggest
yeah i mean so first step in stepping
internationally is creating content that
speaks to that market right so
it has to be english language obviously
if you're talking to america but but the
american market is different than the
british market it's different than the
australian market so it's creating
content that really speaks
to that market and one thing that really
helped me when i was launching my first
business and software was i worked with
local people to help me create content
that spoke to that local market so
for you instead of just trying to
instead of trying to attack you know 20
markets all at the same time i picked
the one that you think has the most
opportunity so
if it's america if it's france if it's
somewhere else in europe whatever it is
pick that one market and then talk to
people who really know that market well
and and create content and create a
website that really speaks to those
people well it's better to do one market
really well than 20 markets in a really
you know mediocre way
so what do you suggest i start with one
particular market or i focus
how do i focus into one particular
market what is uh
how do you build your traffic so if
you're looking at the american market
for example then you need to have the
dot-com website for your brand right
american
we don't want to go well i'm canadian
but whatever north americans you know it
can be scary to go to a website that
doesn't end in dot com you know even if
i see something that is dot co dot uk i
know that's a uk market i'm probably not
gonna order something from there or i'm
gonna be a little less willing to click
on that link because i want stuff that's
related to my market so you want to get
the dot com first of all right i don't
know if you already have that or not if
you use it or not but
super
okay perfect so then it's creating
content that speaks to if it's north
america it speaks to north american
market so what are the problems that
north americans are going through right
now and how can your herbs
solve it
right to creating articles that are that
are specific right what are north
americans searching for if you use that
google keyword tool that i talked about
you can pick markets in there you can
look at canada versus united states
versus india versus great britain you
can pick those markets out and see what
people actually care about
because that's the key okay
what's great in india may not be great
for americans and so you need to target
your content
understood so i have to go with
individual code contacts to make the
which is the key to export success means
i need uh
market planning as per the cultural
advantage of the country and i need
sufficient groundwork to
begin with
yeah i am even be great as well to see
if you can find somebody in the markets
to help you to help educate you on the
market and potentially represent you uh
when i was when i had my software
company i was exporting
you know i didn't want to deal with all
of the international markets because i
didn't really know the culture the
language so if i would sell into japan
you know the time zone is completely
different i don't speak japanese you
know i don't know the culture i don't
want to offend people and so i partnered
up with a local japanese company and
they helped represent my product in that
market so that really helped get an
understanding of the local markets as
well so if you can
look at who would be a potential seller
for you who understands the local
markets trying to go to they can help
rapidly expand everything for you
instead of you trying to figure it all
out yourself
okay one more question sir your zoogee
guide
it's one particular book which contains
all the subjects or it is different
different books
yeah so my zuger package uh you can you
can look it online at
developerconference.com and it's
it's a package so it's meant to be used
for entrepreneurs who are growing their
business um you can buy some of them
individually but you can you can also
get the whole package together
so if i buy the whole package i will get
all the contents uh on the email or you
will send us the when i order you will
send us the white paper book
yeah it's all downloadable so as soon as
you order it you can download it it's a
whole bunch of different pdfs almost 40
different pdfs you can download print
and explore
we have got a run to our next commercial
break but thank you so much for calling
in regime it's great to see the twitter
connection and uh actually thank you
thank you sir today we're talking about
online marketing we've been sharing some
tools and resources to help you grow
your business online and now i'm excited
to have a special guest on with us his
name is edward kundal he runs business
creator plot and he's an expert in local
search marketing ed welcome to the
program
thank you thank you for having me on
awesome so and what's what's the biggest
mistake that most people make when
they're trying to rank locally
oh um
i think it's it's they don't really
optimize their site i mean there's a lot
of components to to online um marketing
um they don't do cert they don't they
also have their their citations uh
they'll set the citations up correctly
um you know they don't
claim their listings they don't do any
social marketing they don't do any video
marketing
um you know they have to be concerned
about reviews and they have to optimize
their website for local search
so how how is local search different
from regular search for those of
listening who may not understand what's
happening here
i think local search is about ranking a
business instead of a website um it's
it's that's really what we want to stand
out
and i consider local search marketing as
the umbrella
service for pyramid
to local marketing local search getting
found locally
so do i have to have a local office for
this to work can it work for any
business or only retail outlets how does
it work
well any business that has a local
region even national firms seeking to
penetrate local markets uh should be
doing local structural marketing
any business who advertises in the local
print media or local tv
should be
need to be utilizing local search
marketing includes restaurants lawyers
dentists cosmetic surgeons accountants
chiropractors
home improvement firms roofers i can't
think of anyone who shouldn't be doing
local search marketing
and and the local search just to kind of
clarify is you know when you're typing
in
something in google and you include a
city or country or town uh it's that
part at the top where you see those
listings and then there's the map next
to it right and then you see the rest of
the results
that's correct but but it's more than
that as well it's i mean we have to we
can't discount mobile because mobile is
just overtaking
desktop searches so more than 50 percent
of searches are done mobily so we have
to make sure that website is
is ready for that mobile market and
interestingly enough um you know eighty
percent of actually it's eighty percent
of of um business owners think their
website
um is is mobile ready and in fact um
ninety percent of websites are not
mobile ready
and i guess especially important for for
local search right because somebody
might be somewhere around your office
and trying to find it and if your
website's not loading properly it's a
big deal
yeah and in fact it's 74 74 of
smartphone shoppers
make a purchase as a result of using
their smartphones
um and 80 percent of the 88 of those
look for local information on their
smartphones take action within a day
so you're losing a big part of your
market unless you're mobile optimized
yeah so when i'm on my desktop and i do
a google search
i see the map that comes up and i see
the 10 local businesses and that shows
up before all the other listings so it's
super important
how does that show up on mobile how does
locals show up on mobile versus their
regular search results
well um it's mostly local search that
shows up on mobile because google knows
where you are and you're geo targeted
and i want to point out on your desktop
search there's such a fluctuation right
now and the way mobile is is being
presented by google
um you know
you've heard of the carousel if you look
up a lot of restaurants you'll see a
carousel on top well that's going to be
implemented across the board that's
local search so it's not that what we
used to call a seven pack and then a ten
pack um you know seven or ten businesses
and they're not that's not even true
anymore you don't always get a seven or
a ten pack you don't always get that
local listing there sometimes you get
the carousel up on top so it's important
to optimize your website to have
especially a restaurant and that's
really where google
put this out first on the carousel
you have to have a really nice image
show up there because if you just have
the map show up if you don't have an
image show up there if you're not
optimized for for that
um google will just pull up a little map
location that looks very ugly and very
likely to get passed on so and
interestingly enough it's no longer top
to bottom it's left to right so you can
have a really great display in the
middle and if you turned it
up vertically
you might be in the middle of the pack
but because you have a nice display
horizontally and you're in the middle
you're going to get more clicks
right
interesting a lot a lot of work though
so if i'm getting started and i'm
listening to you i'm saying wow you know
what i never even thought about local
search i got to get into this what are
my steps
well initially what we do is we we look
where you're at um and we go through a
process of optimizing the site for local
search um and basically we do a lot of
on-site content
with show targeted tags meaning we need
to let google
know exactly where you are and what your
service area is
you certainly don't want to be being you
know you don't want to have a i'm in
allentown pa you don't want an allentown
um listing showing up locally
in california it's not going to do you
any good so we optimize the pages with
local tags um and keeping in mind also
when you do a search google knows where
you are either intuitively
or not
either you're going to put in allentown
pa or just because i'm sitting in front
of my computer
and my ip is an allentown ip it's going
to know where i'm sitting so it's going
to deliver those results and somebody in
florida is going to get different
results if they search for the same
thing
even with an allentown pa tag
so search results are very much dynamic
um you know that's why
nobody really looks at ranking reports
anymore seriously because they change
they can change within a day
um
and and
more frequently than that
and again it also depends where you are
and it also depends on your search
history so there's a lot of components
that go into it
so what are the elements that i need to
get started you said i need to have a
great picture that showcases my business
well do i need a video what else do i
need to get started
what i would do is i would we would
optimize the site we would build
citations which are basically uh
listings throughout the internet um
keeping you know name address and phone
number consistent
because google looks for consistency
again you mentioned video video is
extremely important
the reviews are important so we need to
make sure that you have some reviews or
put a program together to help you get
reviews
social marketing is critical there um in
mobile marketing mobile marketing is a
must it's no longer an option
and those are those are the key elements
of what i consider local search
marketing
uh yeah i like the reviews and i know
when i see a business that has good
reviews you know i'm more likely to to
check them out and trust them
how do you
what kind of programs you set up to
encourage people to leave reviews
well we we try to make it as easy as
possible um and and so we have a program
that you can actually put um the review
component the piece of that on your
website so people go to your website
leave a review and that will get
distributed uh through the internet
and then we get email reminders hey
please you know thank you for the review
please leave a review um you know on
google plus or or you know uh yelp or or
whatever you know where else we want to
get you located depending on the
business type
and the other thing is you know the
other component of that is
um
people need to answer good reviews as
well as bad reviews i mean it's nice to
go back to good review and say hey thank
you very much for that great review we
really appreciate your business
people leave that
people leave that out of the of of
review marketing
right so you can't just set it up and
let it go you got to be a little bit
involved to uh to maintain it
you have to be proactive and one of the
things that we did with with the local
dentist is we put a little little laptop
a little actually it's a tablet uh with
the review page up so when people leave
the person behind the camera can say hey
would you would you like to leave a
review for us today so it doesn't leave
their mind they're there they'll leave a
review and then because if they go home
they're going to forget about it they're
not going to do it people are so busy
right
so you have to be very very proactive in
that process and reviews playing a
really extremely important role in
google algorithm for ranking not only
the number but of course you know the
ratings
right do you ever give something away to
ask people to do a review
that's a no-no um
you know
yeah you're not supposed to do that
people do that
um but that's just something that um you
know
it's not something we encourage our
clients to do
is that uh
is that against google's terms of
service or is that just what it is okay
it's not a philosophical thing
yeah
it's not something they they they pretty
much they weren't they were they were
saying they weren't encouraging and then
last year they came out and said yeah we
if we find out you're doing that you
know it's not a good thing
yeah you don't want to be google banned
there
no no
ed it's been amazing talking to you for
for people who are curious and want to
learn more and say hey you know what
like i want somebody to help me do this
i can't handle this on my own how can
people learn more about you
our website is
businesscreatorplus.com and by the way
the company name is business creator uh
the website's
businesscreatorplus.com and our our
phone number is
855.943.8736 36 that's 855 943 87 36 and
one of my
people will answer the phone and so will
i
awesome thank you so much ed
thank you
i want to share one last tool with you
and it's google analytics goals google
analytics is a great tool put it on your
website it's free it tracks how many
people visit your site
what sources they're coming from what
keywords they're using
but more important is goals and what you
want to do this is free it takes a
little bit of technical knowledge
instead of that but definitely worth
investigating is you want to track
leads not just visitors and so the
further along can get somebody in the
sales path if you're an e-commerce site
it's on the actual sales confirmation
page if you're uh if you're a service
provider nobody's buying anything but
maybe they're calling you so maybe it's
your contact page basically separate a
lead from just a visitor right if
somebody visits your contact page
they're more likely to be a lead than
somebody who just hits their homepage
and bounces and so if you set up goals
and you put a little piece of code on
that page your contact page or your sale
confirmation page then you can tell
what sources lead to prospects
what sources are leading to sales what
keywords to use to leak the sales or
what traffic source is leading to sales
so you should definitely check it out
google goals through google analytics
it's free and can give you a lot better
information to plan your online
marketing campaigns i want to get to the
calls we got time for one last caller i
have who do i have i have michael on the
line michael where are you from how can
i help
hey how's it going i'm from uh new york
city queens
um you know i'm in a niche market uh
what i do is i sell magic dvds for
magicians playing cards custom decks of
playing cards and apparel now okay i
want to break into a bigger market
because the nature market is cool but it
is small and i know with the apparel on
the playing cards i can definitely go
into something bigger i'm just not sure
how to make that transition yet
well what is the bigger picture for you
is it still magicians or you want to
target somebody new
well i think with the playing cards and
the apparel i think it could become very
universal where it's just not just for
magic because i know i've noticed a lot
of people coming to my store are poker
players people involved in poker people
just collect playing cards some people
buy the shirts because they like the
shirts and want to wear them
so i was thinking more of a lifestyle
brand versus just focusing on magicians
got it so who's the next logical market
is the poker players
i would think so but i'm not in the
poker market so i'm not sure if that's
the best route
so it's figuring out yeah it's tough
when you're not passionate about it
right and this this is the thing right
it's got to be something that you are
passionate about and look credible being
in that market like magicians can look
at you and say hey this guy knows what
he's doing he knows what he's talking
about he's got all this stuff i feel
like this is a home for me yeah the
poker player looks at it they say some
of them i think it's cool but a lot of
them don't feel like this is a home
for them you want to reach those guys in
a big way they have to feel like this is
a home for poker players
is there
that you like that you have a affinity
to somehow that still relates to the
cards of the
apparel
yeah i think the clothing line because i
think the um a lot of the shirts are
based off of playing cards like really
unique spades um the the deck of cards
that i'm just releasing now on
kickstarter is a deck of cards based off
of um native american
sort of styling where um you know i call
them malin playing cards because
designed to be
this sort of deck of cards based off
native american gaming um so there's
another market that i could tap into
are you native
i'm not no but um it's just something
that i found really interesting and uh
the designer that i worked with um says
he has a lot of experience in that so we
you know i just did research on it and
found what i liked about it and just
incorporated into something i do love
which is playing cards yeah cool you
know what i'm that could be a great
model as long as it's authentic right if
i'm if i'm native for example if i'm
interested in native stuff and i see
your cards i want to feel like you
actually care about me and you're not
just trying to make a buck
yeah yeah i mean behind people have a
pretty high bx meter right they can see
if it's just a sales and marketing thing
or like this guy actually cares about my
community you know like magicians it's a
community you try to help each other out
you know who
the you know the haters are and you know
who really
are you know the people who love this
right and so people will come to you
because you've created that home for
them and and maybe your path is through
partnerships quite honestly right if you
love making cards and that's what you
love spreading maybe it's partnering up
with people who have an authentic
affinity towards different markets so
like this artist you partnered up with
to attack the native market
and then you can create content and web
page and marketing that brings both of
your stories together to help reach a
new market
that's great i think that's exactly what
i was looking for
yeah and then you could reach out to
native groups and people who care about
that that that market with authenticity
they say hey we're doing this look at
what we've created we want to we want to
celebrate native americans in the native
community
and and you want them their endorsement
to go out and share it with their
audience right and if they feel like you
actually care you're authentic they're
going to want to help you
yeah yeah that makes a lot of sense
so can i
squeeze it
yeah i can't squeeze in one more
question there yeah quick
so uh real quick my my distributor who i
sell to they since we do produce magic
dvds and playing cards they just
recently started producing now they say
the distributor so they buy from us and
then they sell wholesale so they get a
distributor rates now they're now that
they're producing they're doing their
own playing card designs and producing
their own dvds
i feel like they're becoming sort of
competition do you think it's time that
i should just move on
and continue with this path like you
said with partnerships with other
organizations and just move forward or
should i hold on to my distributor just
in case um how would i play that
it doesn't hurt to have a backup plan
you know
they can't replicate what you're doing
right like if you're making these unique
partnerships with
artists they can't go out and do the
exact same thing right
you're coming from a place where you
love playing cards and you're authentic
about it so that's that's real where
they're just trying to model and copy
somebody else but they're not really
behind it it's not going to work out but
it's good to have a backup plan another
distributor just in case this one falls
through or the relationship source
i wouldn't be so worried about them
eating your market though because what
you're doing is different that nobody
else like i've never heard of native
american playing cards and all the other
awesome stuff you're going to come up
with
so i wouldn't worry so much about them
eating your lunch just continue being
innovative and different and if you need
to find a new distributor then you need
to find a distributor
great thank you so much i really
appreciate it i think that's going to
help me out a lot no problem you know
what i want to see a lot of entrepreneur
trading cards
yeah that's a great idea i'm gonna work
on that yeah you make that happen let me
know i'll help you promote it
absolutely
all right thanks michael
thank you so much have a good day you
too all right we're already up at the
end of the hour it's crazy how fast
everything goes thank you guys for
having a great show i will be back in
two weeks thank you to my amazing
producers daniella and josh you guys
rock could not do it without you
everybody listening i will see you in
two weeks have a great time continue to
believe in your business and have fun